today's speaker we have yonkou Yanis the
what's up what's up as we mentioned an
earlier iteration of this is the startup
that did everything right after not
getting after trying to get jobs at
Facebook and not for either Yann or
Brian they put their heads down they
figured out a product that people really
wanted and while everybody else in
Silicon Valley was going to conferences
doing PR whatever else it is people do
other than making the products that
people really love whatsapp just quietly
built this thing that was used by how
many people the time of the acquisition
of 450 450 million people for a consumer
app and more than a billion now it was
acquired by Facebook a couple of years
ago and young can tell that story but
thank you very much for coming to talk
to us sir
thanks for having me so one semi asked
me to do to come and speak here I think
I made some smartass comment how I'm
going to speak about like people
actually building a product and not not
going to class or something like that
but as I mentioned we were just
fortunate in a way that we stumbled into
something that people really want it and
I'll explain in a second how would God
there but the credit really goes to not
necessarily us having some brilliant
idea I think the credit goes to like
also being in the right time in the
right place and building a product that
that people wanted and just realizing
that that people wanted it so just to
kind of give these the quick history of
how we got where we got we actually both
mean my co-founder bride who were at
Yahoo for about I was there for nine
years he was there for 11 years and that
time was actually really really valuable
for us to learn how to scale back end
servers how to what makes a good product
what makes a bad product and kind of
seen the the Yahoo as a company get
really successful than kind of you know
the story so well left in 2007 just
going to downplay we both left around
the same time like
a month difference and we did some time
off we took about a year off so so we'll
effort 2007 we took all of 2008 off he
moves to New York with his girlfriend I
was just like goofing off and and I
really kind of fell in love with my
Nokia phone I had this candy bar I think
was 6610 Nokia phone that I jail broke
and stole like an admin software on it
which showed you like which mobile cell
you were connected to and like all this
advanced things you could do with the
phone that you couldn't do when you took
it out of the box and so at the end of
2008 I went traveling I went to
Argentina I went to Russia to Ukraine to
Hungary to Israel to a bunch of
countries so I was gone for like two
three months on and off and what I found
really hard during the time was just
keeping in touch with my friends it
special in Argentina I don't know if
anybody here is from Argentina or been
to Argentina like there you go so one
person what's with your dialling code
like it's so complicated I could never
understand it and so when we were in
Argentina just like having people call
us or me calling people like I went to
got a local SIM card but I couldn't
figure out have people call me because
of these weird complicated dialing codes
and preferences and I was just like oh
so this is how 2008 and and January of
2009 my birthday was coming up in
February and I figure like I'll get
myself an early birthday present I'll go
buy an iPhone so I went to Apple store
bought an iPhone and right around the
same time as the cake came out I think
there was no as decay when iPhone first
came out in 2007 but I think they
released it at September of 2008 so I
was like literally three four months
after iPhone came out sorry after iOS
SDK came out I got an iPhone and I
started like tinkering with it I was
also really bored when I had a lot of
free time so I'm like okay well let's
install this weird thing called Xcode
luckily I had a Mac let's install Xcode
let's figure out what what can be done
let's build a some simple app and then
you kind of like realize holy it
has full internet connectivity and it
can do full tcp/ip stack so it basically
is a little computer that
talk to your server so I'm like okay
cool what what can we do with it so the
first thing that we built which I don't
know how many of you know the history of
what's up the first thing that we built
was actually just going to play with
status and so the idea was if you ever
used and y'all might be too young for
this favor use something like AOL a.m.
or ICQ or IRC or any of these products
you have this concept of a status like
Yahoo Messenger heads is like away from
keyboard or I'm busy or am in a meeting
and so the first thing that you would do
when you use those messengers as you
would like the first message you would
send was hey are you there that was like
the first message you sent to start a
conversation with somebody on like ICQ
or if you private message somebody on
IRC because people would be away and so
they would use the status to kinda
indicate like I'm not near a computer or
I'm afk or whatever and so the idea was
like well let's take this concept of
status and just like apply it to your
phone so before people call you they can
check your status like maybe you're busy
maybe you're in a meeting maybe you're
traveling whatever so if you don't pick
up of those people know why you don't
pick up and that was kind of like the
whatsapp 1.0 application and what they
built was the the app that hooked into
your address book so the other things
that kind of worked in our favor was
there were address book api's on a
mobile phone they didn't really exist on
a desktop right if you think about
desktop like Windows from 2000 to 2008
ish people never really put address
books from their desktop people always
had address books on their mobile phones
and so even if the API existed there was
like nothing to query because the
address book database was empty on all
these on all these devices and so
luckily the the one thing that Apple
opened was their address book api's
which was great for us so what we did
was sorry basically went through the
address book and we could figure out if
the contact in your address book was
another whatsup user
and that's basically how the status work
we would take your phone number and it
was an international phone number we
would try to like normalize it to the
plus format so your phone numbers would
start all the phone numbers in our
system would start with the plots in the
full international format and we would
be able to detect if the other person is
a person on a watsapp network a user of
our product and the idea was that before
you start before you start a phone call
or before you send a message you would
check the status of this person from
what's up and they would say oh I'm
available and you would call right so
that was the what's up 1.0
it failed horribly like it was a
disaster it was depressing
nobody nobody used it people downloaded
it actually surprisingly enough and I
think people downloaded it because there
are like no ABS back at the time they
were like maybe I don't know a thousand
or two thousand apps and the whole app
store because it just it just went live
so we we benefited from being early but
the idea wasn't so great so people would
download and they say just like never
use it people just call people like they
normally would it was really hard to
replace like a native dialer and that's
kind of what we wanted to do we wanted
to replace a native dialing application
so we we struggled for a little bit we
kept adding all these like weird
features in retrospect back then without
they were like the best thing ever
like you could set your status to
automatically change at a certain time
of day like if you knew you were always
in a meeting from like 2:00 to 4:00 you
could like automatically configure it to
always say that you're in a meeting from
2:00 to 4:00 so kind of like that
functionality and then something
happened around the summer of 2009 Apple
introduced push notifications so back
then if you wanted the application to
wake up there's only way to wake it up
was the user tapping on an application
icon and there was no way to do anything
in the background which in retrospect
was really backwards because I don't
know if any of you know about Nokia
Symbian phones but like s60 and
Blackberry had all this capability even
before iPhone came out to do auto start
to do background multitasking to do
networking to do all the stuff and so
like iOS actually limited what we can do
so we're like struggling and then Apple
introduced push notifications we were
like hallelujah
so we ended up hooking into Apple push
notifications I think this was like
around the summertime even before they
were still in beta because we had
developer access and we we noticed that
people were using the status of the way
to kind of communicate with each other
they would change the status to say like
I'm going to a bar and like the change
in status would like broadcast and go to
all the other people who use what's up
in their address book and so around the
summer of 2009 were like huh interesting
maybe we should build messaging and then
it all kind of clicked because I've
always use it as a mess and if you
remember on the old Nokia phones the SMS
was not threaded so you would get a
message which was the phone number and
if you get any other message from that
person that would show up with just like
another entry in your in your list and
then iOS came out and they introduced
threaded SMS and everybody was like wow
so we kind of said okay well we can do
full networking with the new tcp/ip we
can connect phone if your phone is
declined to to a server on the back end
we already had all this code to figure
out if your whatsapp user or not we
could take your phone number parsad
figuring out figure out all the like
international preferences we haven't
figured out Argentina at some point
which was not an easy thing to do but we
got there so so we got we got to to a
state where we could actually send
messaging have people send messages or
what's up and if you look at our
application today you see all this
features they see group chat with the
ability to send media to record voice
messages to do all the stuff we didn't
have any of it we didn't have like the
only thing we had was one-on-one
messaging that's it just think how
antiquated that is and that's what we'll
lunch with so around September I think
it was September ish maybe maybe late
August early September is maybe even
early October actually I remember is
when we launched messaging and it took
off and and it was intuitive to us wise
to cook because SMS was so expensive
back in those days right and a special
internationalism s so if you had two
people who were living in two different
countries
how did they communicate well they could
send each other some s it was expensive
they could use Skype but Skype also
worked on a desktop so you had to like
synchronize the time when both of your
in front of a computer and you know
people usually are not like some of you
have computers open boot if you get a
Skype call now you're not going to
answer it right so there was really no
good way for people to like communicate
in real-time and so that's why some s
was so popular because your phone was
always with you it was always in your
pocket it was always no matter where you
want you had your phone with you so when
you sent an SMS you never said hey I use
there like you never did it you just
send an SMS
the only thing sometimes you could say
is hey did you get my message because
system s was so unreliable especially
internationally and so that was the
other problems that we could solve by
building on top of tcp/ip is we could
add reliability in our protocol so we
rolled out messaging we made it super
reliable we added all these visual
indicators you knew the message actually
was successfully delivered to a server
Union food was successfully delivered to
the device that you were sending it to
and and it just took off and and when
when Sam talked about like well we kind
of like when heads down and we didn't go
to conferences and we didn't do a whole
lot of other stuff it's just because we
were lucky we stumbled into something
that people really really had a need for
to think about SMS back in 2006-2007
right there was no iMessage nothing else
worked on your phone SMS was expensive
it was horribly limiting you can only
send 160 characters at a time and if you
send a longer messages would break it
into multiple chunks and some tablets
sometimes like the chunk of the bottom
would arrive first so you have to like
read the message at the bottom and then
reads a message on top for after that
media was horribly expensive and it was
not working well across platforms so if
I sent like the video recorded on Nokia
phone to blackberry users they probably
couldn't have watched it or if you send
the video recorded on blackberry iPhone
it probably wouldn't work either
so we had all these limitations of the
semesters what we're trying to address
in our product and obviously the biggest
almost cost SMS was very expensive in
Europe and and in many countries outside
of North America and we just kept going
so once we figured out that there isn't
eat for it we were like well we better
hire so we hired some of our old friends
from Yahoo who left the Apple some of
our actually aho friends
we hired I hired a friend of mine who I
actually met when I was working at
Stanford like when I was doing IT at
Graduate School of Business in like 96
97 ish like when I was in high school so
he came and he helped work on a
blackberry client and so our goal was
like okay well we got to build all the
features but also got to build all these
platforms because we started out whose
iPhone but the world back then was very
different
Nokia actually was majority smartphone
platform back in the days not in North
America but if you'll kind of looked at
the rest of the world everybody was
using Nokia smartphones and blackberry
and Android I think didn't even exist or
just barely existed in the end of 2009
and early 2010 so we had to build for
Nokia and we had to find people who
could actually build for Nokia Symbian
s60 and we had to find those people in
Europe because nobody in Silicon Valley
even heard of Nokia so we got lucky we
found two really good engineers to help
us build that finally story about our
Nokia client it actually built on the
top it's actually built using Python not
a lot of people know that actually Nokia
60 had a Python runtime so remember when
when Brian my co-founder he was started
looking at Nokia because we knew that we
had to do Nokia so you kind of went away
for a week he comes back a week later
he's like you're not going to believe
this you can build you can build you can
use Python to build a client I was like
no way get out of here like no no no no
no seriously you don't understand you
can run Python on this little tiny phone
I was like okay let's try and do it and
that's what we did
the-the-the basically the whole back-end
the communications the protocol was all
in Python and the you I was actually in
C++ so we started working on building
multiple platforms and we started
working on building features so we
launched blackberry we launched Nokia 60
and Royd always on a few months of each
other in 2010 and then we started
building features so we had to build
what people asked us to build people
want a group chat everybody's like this
is great I love your product I want to
have a group conversation with my family
or you know three friends or
five core workers or ten people in a
study group and we're like okay well how
do we build group job let's figure it
out to like sit down and sketch the user
experience then figure out how to make
the backend system work for group chat
and then people wanted obviously we had
very quickly we added multimedia and I
think multimedia is what really took us
to the next level like once we added
ability to send the picture which today
is like comical like how could you not
have ability to send the picture through
a messaging product over your smart
phone back then you couldn't there was
nothing that worked really well or what
cheaper was reliable so added ability to
send a picture we added ability to some
videos we at some point introduced voice
messages and and then things just took
off and so at that point it was just
scaling the back end and this is where
it kind of ties into what I was talking
about earlier were mean Brian worked at
Yahoo because we spend so much time
there and because we were there in early
days and we saw the company's scale we
had all this experience to to scale the
back end and we had our own fair we had
our own share of outages and our service
wasn't 100% perfect but we would make
sure that we would learn from an outage
and make sure that we would add the
right monitoring in place and we would
have enough capacity always for holidays
like Christmas in years where's the
traffic spike but having that experience
working at Yahoo learning how to scale
the back end systems learning how to
tweak the operating systems the kernels
and networking stack the ethernet driver
if you have to it's all kind of tied
together so our experience at Yahoo our
experience with difficult or challenging
a semester protocol that we'll use as a
consumer kind of all combined with this
perfect timing that happened in
2009-2010 with smartphones coming online
and people wanting to have this ability
to communicate and if you think about
smartphone it's ultimately like the
messaging is the killer app for a
smartphone so we just basically like
stumbled and do the killer app because
there is nothing else you do more with
the smartphone than communicate most
most of it is probably talking to your
friends and family and your loved ones
either over iMessage or whatsapp or
Skype or anything else yes okay
would you do it again ha could you make
another up again to take so imagine yeah
we're just an app chat thing yeah I put
it up for you can I read it was just one
we've been successful we gather like
zero so the odds are in the or side so
you should you should go and do
something so that's why we were able to
actually spend all of our time
head down building a product because we
had this amazing product market fit we
had this amazing product that people
wanted they were like give me give me
give me when we were rolling out Nokia
s40 which was just like a step below
Nokia 60 which was kind of like a
picture phone
people were like emailing us asking for
like when is this going to be done when
is it going to be done once it was going
to be done and so there was like a huge
pent-up demand for any platform before
we would launch it and so that's why we
didn't have like a need to go to the
conferences and do a lot of PR or or do
anything like that because we had people
who needed our product and we had like
millions of people who were waiting for
us to build a new feature or a new
platform and that's why we were able to
just go ahead top and go ahead down and
build a product so that was kind of like
the background that I wanted to give on
how we got started we can do a Q&A for
the next 15-20 minutes and yeah this is
your most about it how you dealt with
the launch of iMessage and Facebook
Messenger and all the messaging
platforms like what that was clearly
first and ever it looked the world got
scary quickly how did you think about
that boys like oh so how does it think
about iMessage in all these other
platforms well so was I message we when
does it launch I think 2011 ish
something like that
I think 2011 at the developer conference
so the the world and Silicon Valley is
very different from the world outside so
in Silicon Valley if you look around
like 90 percent of people have an iPhone
not only does it have an iPhone they
have like a late of greatest iPhone
outside of Silicon Valley it's like 80
or 90 percent Android right so for us
having an iMessage launch was just like
a small blip on a radar so Facebook
Messenger so I think Facebook for the
very long time didn't really have a good
messaging story I remember they bought
this company called Beluga which I think
was Beluga that was group messaging so
they were kind of focused on group
messaging at first and then they shut it
down and turn it into Facebook Messenger
but Facebook Messenger was part of the
Facebook app it wasn't really dedicated
app back in the days but ultimately if
you look at a facebook Messenger the the
graph that the Facebook Messenger is
using it's very different from the graph
on your phone and if you think about
people you add to your address book and
people who you add on Facebook there's
going to be some overlap but for the
most part it's going to be different so
people who I add on Facebook are
probably not people who I'm going to
message with a lot and people who I put
in my address book are people who are
probably a different graph in terms of
like how important they are to me and if
I add you into my basically if I
exchange a number with somebody it means
that gives them ability to like what's
up me as some ask me or call me there
are probably a lot of people who I'm
friends with on Facebook whose if they
called me I wouldn't I would probably
like first go like who is this oh yeah
we met each other once and I added them
I'm probably not necessarily a typical
example I mean I'm sure there are people
who have different graphs on different
networks I'm sure there are people who
use what's up on me for work and they
only have their co-workers on the what's
up on there in their address book and
I'm sure that there are people who only
have a certain set of their contacts in
one or the other but I think overall
this idea of like well if I add it to my
phone and you permission to interrupt my
life is what makes our network a little
different because people are people have
this these connections that are stronger
with people who they have in each
other's address book with with
Facebook you know I have people I went
to high school with their people I went
to university with and it's great that I
can keep in touch with them on Facebook
but I wouldn't want them to call me like
randomly out of the blue at 7 p.m. it
would be just like awkward - they
haven't talked to them for years so so
the graphs are different in that sense
and so so we always had kind of going
back and generalizing it will always
have competition from like day one we
there was actually a point in time where
there was a new messaging app popping up
like every month and every month was an
article on TechCrunch how this awesome
new messaging app is going to like take
down all other messaging apps and I
don't know if they paid tech knowledge
to write it or what but um every we just
read this and we'll go like they have no
users how can you write that story in
TechCrunch it just like makes no sense
and obviously we didn't want to say
anything because we don't want to draw
attention to ourselves well actually on
purpose like try to standards radar but
it was just like kind of funny to see
this from from from the sidelines all
this kind of like dog and pony show that
happened with all these apps I mean
there was sting me there was message me
there was group means there was kids
there was they were like hello there
were like 10 different messaging apps at
some point which kept getting all this
publicity and we were like good for you
have the publicity Awards we'll just
enter the radar and not get not have any
attention Joan to us so we always have
competition these big guys like iMessage
or facebook Messenger be it little guys
like kick we always have competition we
always live in today we still have apps
like telegram out there and line and
Kakao but what we said that our destiny
is really in our hands like we can't
worry too much about competition we have
to worry about our product and our users
and if we spend a lot of time thinking
about competition or looking at
competition we're going to fail
yeah and I'm trying to build on while
you just talk about this social graph I
mean I mean I feel like that this whole
social graph and it's actually now
changing like I mean at least among me
and my friends I mean I think I don't
call people like so much other beast and
then like you know SMS I will probably
add people mostly on this social media
like online Facebook or I could add them
on the chat
so I get what's it and more bye if you
like this whole social graph it is there
so like changing slowly because people
call mess and be both dead
SMS let people like you drill on this
social media come to you do you have a
view on that and you didn't get any like
opportunity on that or do you think
during this sheet that's even true on oh
I think yeah English truth so the
question was like how is it the world is
changing people coalesce and now like
people add like the social network so
kind of merge into one now yeah you're
right I think people call less these
days and people most a message each
other I don't really know if we would do
anything differently today or even back
then I think for us the focus has always
been on like well will we want to
provide a utility we want to provide an
application that is purely only about
communication so if you look at some
other apps like be chat or line or cacao
so they do a lot of different things
right
you can like order taxes through V chat
and you can follow people online like
mine has a whole feed concept and we
always wanted to build something that is
really really efficient and utilitarian
and also fast and reliable I mean not a
lot of people can have the latest and
greatest smartphone right a lot of
people have Android phones that are
low-end a lot of people have or used to
have Blackberry phones they didn't have
a lot of horsepower and a lot of memory
and a lot of CPU so for us it was always
about reliability and efficiency of the
app and not trying to do all these
different things that lot of different
social networks and apps do ya think
about messenger right now because not
unless you integrated a lot of the
teachers at once I'm not I am so huge
messenger a lot more and that definitely
takes away from the eternal lotta so do
you have an internal competition
nobody's eternal is there is still a lot
of room for both apps to grow I think
Messenger is really strong in countries
like North America like the United
States for example so I think we
complement each other geographically I
think if you look at
just like India or Israel or Hong Kong
or Germany or Spain whatsapp has really
strong foothold in those countries and I
think if you look at something like
Australia or North America you're
probably going to see messenger do
really well so a lot of it is also not
necessarily split by a graph but also by
the country you're in okay appreciate
the humility that you couldn't do it
again with another app but I I'm sure
people ask you all the time to eat you
know for help right advice how do you
determine if you you're an idea or look
at an application it can be really well
how do you think yes so reasonable
question is how do you determine if if
an app has a potential or is a good idea
um it has to solve a really basic
problem and it has to do it in a really
simple and efficient way when going back
to what we'd build we in some ways solve
a problem right people had problem
communicating when they were not in the
same room when they were in different
cities or in different countries or in
different time zones and so it's not
that it wasn't impossible
it just it was hard and it was expensive
and we made it easier and cheaper and
when you offer something to people that
is easier and cheaper people of course
will will use it so I think the number
one thing to look at for me when I look
at a product does it's all we need
and doesn't solving it on a global scale
right if you solve a need for people on
Stanford campus that's great but can it
scale to a billion or two billion people
if you saw we need four people only in
Silicon Valley by providing them charges
for their Tesla's great how many people
have tehsils in the world right it's got
to be like a global um actually a lot of
people at desk I don't know but it's got
to be like a global solution that
applies to everybody in every country
potentially right and so that was kind
of like sort of get wrong as you said in
Silicon Valley everyone's got the iPhone
7 after whatever well now how did she
build that into the culture of the
company could think about
you use all around away I know we got
lucky with the people who hired and that
was other things that I didn't mention
that I should have mentioned when it up
was a really incredible team that we
mostly hired out of her personal network
from from exile and from like friends of
friends we I think ourselves had a
really good understanding I mean me
myself being an immigrant and like
growing up in other country and going to
all these other countries
I understood that that there was more to
smartphone than just iPhone that was
like the things that everybody talked
about and wrote about in 2008 in 2009 so
like for me especially somebody who
really liked Nokia phones before not
giving out of business I was like we got
a built for market because they're great
phones and there's like a billion Nokia
smartphones out there so I think just me
and my co-founder having that
perspective probably distilled through
the company and people understood that
hey you know the you don't want to just
build for iPhones you don't want to just
build for the latest and greatest you
have all these millions of phones out
there
billions of phones out there that you
got to build for because you want those
users to be using your product and they
also were asking us to do that
yes congenic on the business side
it's very incorporation equity and
raising money a business a very buck
sure so we incorporated on my birthday
on February 24th of 2009 and the reason
I was thinking that was going to so let
me back up we were trying to submit an
app into the Apple Store and I didn't
want to do it under my own name like I
didn't want the app to say yeah I'm cool
because I figured like who would want to
install an app made by some guy so I
figure like we should probably be more
official we should have like a company
I'm like okay so go to Google how do you
start a company right it's just like
step step one
so I got a friend of mine he was he was
an insurance broker so he had his own
company and he was like three blocks
away from me in Santa Clara where were
where I lived and so I went to his
office because I used to buy insurance
for my car in my house from him and so I
was like dude how did you incorporate
he's like oh it's easy you take these
Articles of Incorporation it's like one
page with like five things written in it
and you go to San Francisco to the State
Building the Secretary of State or
whatever and it gives them a hundred
dollars in this town but then you're
done
I'm like no way can visit easy he's like
yeah it's that easy I'm like all right
so we had to submit an app and and they
wanted us to show like Apple Store
wanted us to actually send them a copy
of the incorporation articles so it was
like okay easy I'm nothing to do that
day I'm like drive to San Francisco get
lunch go to the office get a stamp get a
letter great send it to Apple say they
look at the letters that are like yep
you're legit you're a company you can
now submit under the name what's up I'm
not cool submit it in that understanding
what's up so that's what's how we
incorporate it in terms of in terms of
it's easier than it sounds back then it
was like a struggle for me because I
never done it how did we think about
money or the whole funding thing so we
we left yahoo with some savings because
yahoo did really well in late 90s early
2000s and so we had stock we had options
we had our issues and so I was actually
able to like not only take a year off
obviously not do anything extravagant
but like live off my savings for a year
and then I had enough money to where
while I was still thinking around with
an app and we didn't have exuberant cost
I actually remember like when we started
out I was using my buddy's server this
guy Chuck who also used to work at Yahoo
he used to run Yahoo Sports and so like
I used to sit next to the Apple sports
team so we became friends so I was like
hey Chuck can I use the server I don't
want to pay $20 a month for a server
he's like yeah sure so like you know
saving $20 a month on the server was a
big deal for me
and so we would run like originally on
his server and I remember at some point
as well I'm just messaging and like soul
this goes he's like you got to get your
own servers in the Mignogna and I'm fine
I don't want to pay for my own charity
like no no you got to get your own
servers you're like taking up all this
CPU and bandwidth and I'm like no no no
I'm fine I'm fine so answer like he
kicked me out of his kick me off the
server and and which was great to do a
switch from Linux to FreeBSD which well
loved and we had experience was at at
Yahoo and so we were able to actually
for a long time live off our savings and
since we had all this experience on how
to run the company efficiently when it
comes to like servers and back-end and
bandwidth and everything there was not a
lot of expense the expense started when
we had to go hire people and the the
idea was that okay well we need we're
going to have to pay from our servers
we're gonna have to pay for demos we're
going to have to pay for a semester if
occation because to sign up on whatsapp
you have to verify your phone number and
we did a small angel round Canton
remember I think it was end of 2009 we
did a small angel round and then we
basically kind of kept our company
running without losing too much money
because in early days iPhone app was
actually paid like people had to pay $1
to download iPhone app while everything
else was free like Android and
Blackberry nokia and so we had people
paying for iPhone app and that kind of
went to - it gave us ability to pay for
the bill - for electricity for bandwidth
bills for server bills and all that
stuff and I think probably around 2011
2010 2011 ah
people started knocking on the door like
we didn't even went out to look for
money which is a great situation to be
in because like if you're going to go
and raise and you need money you're
probably not going to get the terms you
want which is you know for us was kind
of worked in our favor because all these
we see started coming VC started coming
to us and they're like you guys are
doing great we want to partner with you
we want to give you money and were like
yeah we don't really need it which makes
them want to invest it
more so so so what kind of plate what
kind of did this dance where we're like
no no we don't really want their money
come back in a few months and eventually
like after all these conversations me
and Brian sit down and were like okay
well we we just wasting their time in
our time she would just take funding or
should we not and we decided to shoot
because it's better to have money in
your bank account for your business than
not and that's the words of wisdom that
I got from Jeff Rossen who you know
because Jeff was like if you can have
money in your bank accounts you should
money in your bank account because you
never know if you need to buy a building
or if you need to buy some office space
because you're starting growing too
quickly and you don't want to negotiate
and raise money when it's too late like
you want to do it when you don't need
money
so listening towards the wisdom of Jeff
Ross then we were like okay let's get
some funding and we partnered with
Sequoia and we got money from Sequoia
any any other questions yeah can you
sort of walk it through your like
internal psychology and confidence over
the trajectory of the company like at
the beginning did you identify that the
market timing was pretty spot-on or
where you just sort of like following
what your users were saying to you I
think you're filled with is messaging
when we're doing that
Dinka status feature obviously it was
rough because we had no users and nobody
uses our product until you're like
sitting there in your room building a
product and thinking like well nobody
wants it like why am i doing this what
is the meaning of life and all that
stuff right and so and so you're kind of
like it's tough right when you're
building a product that that people
don't really want if you'll reject it if
you like why aren't you using it is
great I put all my energy in it so so
once we added messaging it was like 180
degrees difference right all of a sudden
everybody wants a product everybody
thinks it's a coolest thing ever we get
all these letters into our own email
inboxes all these emails from people
saying like how great your product is
I'm able to keep in touch with my
fiancee I got married because
your product your product helped me like
save live because the hikers were lost
and the hikers were able to use what's
up share location to scent like it's
just night and day right when people
want your product and they love your
product the the psychology inside a
company is different like people would
come into work and they would be like
we're building the best thing ever
people love the product this is great
and so we didn't really have to do a lot
of selling even to the candidates like
people who came in to interview with us
basically fell into two camps people who
live in the Silicon Valley bubble and
never heard of what's happened they'll
be like why would I want to work for
what's up and people who kind of fell
into like well there is a whole world
out there a bubble and they were like
you guys have millions of users like my
cousin in Spain or my friend in Germany
was talking about your product and
everybody uses it or people would say I
went to India or I went to Middle East
and everybody uses your product it's
like amazing how come nobody heard about
you and they're like well that's the
purpose and so like basically I like
these these two types of people who
would interview and so obviously people
who had like a Silicon Valley bubble
didn't even want to like come work for
us which is not the end of the world
because there were plenty of people who
understood there was a whole big world
out there and they were happy to build
product for hundreds of millions of
users all over the world yeah
how's the fundraising experience part
mystic fire why did we partner with
Sequoia so well then if you had a few
companies give us term sheets one of
them even gave us a blank term sheet
they're like fill out the number you
want we're like well if there's that
that irresponsible with other people's
money maybe we shouldn't we shouldn't do
that shouldn't partner be partnering
with them its acquire is just an amazing
brand right like for me living in
Silicon Valley since 1992 and reading
articles and seeing news about all these
companies at one public like Netscape
and Cisco and Google and knowing that a
lot of them go back by Sequoia just made
it
not a very difficult decision to pick
Sequoia but also really likes people who
work there a lot of it is just personal
chemistry a lot of it is is the VC
company understanding how much to be
hands-on or not like Sequoia was
actually really great about like they
knew the numbers and you were growing
they didn't metal right they didn't need
to come in and say you guys doing this
run or doing that wrong like there was
no need for that and and I think we had
that understanding upfront where they
kind of made us a promise were like
we're here for to help you financially
we're not here to help you with
management when I'm here to help you
write code we're not here to help you
like build features we here just to help
you grow and to help you financially and
if you need any help
outside of that come knock on our door
and we'll try to help and they were
really helpful with stop when they asked
like recruiting or anything like that
they would they would sometimes meet
with prospective candidates and tell
them why they should join what's up so
so Sequoia was really great it was a
brand and and I remember actually when
we had multiple term sheets me and Bryan
went to Jeff Austin's house and we were
talking to him it was late in the
evening we were trying to just get
advice on what should we do and he kind
of like looked at all them and we talked
through all the different term systems
and he kind of said you know like once
you're a Sequoia company or a Sequoia
company it's like that that branding is
really strong and it means a lot yes
welcome for you further how did you get
your first few thousand users back in
the days of aesthetic how did the
universe without music shows oh there
was no apps back then and and iOS
well it wasn't iOS began with iPhone OS
and the Apple Store had this category
new what's new and the the trick was to
submit a new app like every few days so
you would always show up on top of
what's new and you would make a small
change to the name because I think back
in the old days the name difference
triggered you with a new app so we
basically have status in the would say
like status for your smartphone or like
status for your cold or like status for
your iPhone or updated status like we
would basically tweak the name a little
bit with every new version with submit
which always like kept us almost always
at the top of the new category and since
there are no apps people would go to
what's new category all the time to
download to try to download whatever
people would build because like today
you have thousands of apps pegged days
you had like hundreds and basically by
gaming the system a little bit we were
able to I think the phone call got
quotes really quickly but luckily by
that time already had messaging yeah how
did you like Scout app your company I
mean how do you go up like what's up in
two different countries how do we feel
about it yeah oh we didn't have to scale
well we do have to do a couple of things
I think is that so there were two things
that we had to do one we had to build
different platforms because there were
some countries were like AI functions
didn't exist and everybody was using is
there Nokia or Blackberry or a
combination of two the second thing that
we started doing early on is focusing on
localization right so again this kind of
goes back to like Silicon Valley bubble
where everybody in Silicon Valley speaks
English therefore the rest of the world
must speak English not quite so we focus
early on on localization well actually
hired people internally into the company
who were doing two things they were
customer support representative so they
would help people with problems and
write a fake use and help debug issues
but there were also all multilingual so
would hire somebody who's perfect in
Spanish and we would hire somebody who's
perfect in Germany would hire somebody
who is perfect in Portuguese and we
would hire somebody who's perfect in
Italian we would hire somebody who is
perfect and all these languages where
our apps were starting to grow so we
could build a really good localized
experience so when you download what's
up in Brazil it's not in English it's in
Portuguese and I think that is what
helped us grow in all these countries
yeah your first few for you and it came
from your personal networks but how did
you convince them to join you it wasn't
hard most of them were unemployed
so let me see so Brian join so Brian
left Yahoo and he I think didn't really
do anything for like thank you left in
98 so he didn't really do anything for
like 10 years he was one of the earlier
engineers that one Chris my friend who
went from Stanford he I think he was
doing the startup that wasn't really
going anywhere and he was in LA and he
got married to this wonderful girl who
was parents actually from here so like I
think for her it was an advantage to
move here to be closer to her parents
I'm like yeah you guys should move you
guys should move here like move back to
Northern California so the combination
of like her wanting to move to be closer
to her parents and like him not really
doing anything in not having a full-time
job also contributed this guy Eugene who
was one of our early hires he he was
working at a company actually knew him
from my social network who we are in
still friends and like he would always
complain how how he hated his job and
how they were like trying to screw him
over by like promising him stock options
and never delivering it was like he
hated it so I'm like well it was a good
opportunity um we had let's see who else
who hires this guy Michael who was in
New York wasn't really doing anything
also so he was a referral through friend
of mine from Yahoo so there was a guy
Michael Radwin who I used to work with
at Yahoo who was working at a start-up
and Luke would keep in touch and at some
point I was complaining to him how hard
it is to find good engineers that are
smart and capable and can get done
and don't just like sit there and
theorize and it was like oh I know a guy
cause of gum Michael in New York and so
like we randomly call this guy Michael
in New York and I'm like hey Michael
I'll get your name from other Michael
like do you want to comment interview
and I figured like he would say now I'm
pretty happy in New York but he wasn't
really doing much he's like yeah okay so
he came in and intrude and so um we had
let's see we had one of the guys one of
our engineers was in Russia this guy
Igor he wasn't really doing much in
Russia also I felt like they have
Silicon Valley in Russia so we were like
this band of outcasts in some way like
the group of people who weren't really
doing much who got together and build
the product
but there are also people who were
working full-time who actually had to
like try really hard to convince to join
like one one of the guys Rick who helped
us a lot with the backend as we were
scaling the back and he was working at
Yahoo and so like I think it took us six
months of meetings and dinners with me
and Brian trying to convince him and we
would meet him and we would do it like
in very subtle way not like come join us
were like ah you know we have all these
users and we have all this skin and we
knew that he was like really really
technical and he loved solving problems
so we weren't saying like come join us
and you know we'll give you a lot of
mining or options or whatever we were
like playing a different angle but we're
saying like hi Rick if you watching this
who are like hey Rick you know we're
having all these technical problems and
we did and we're like which is don't
know there's like this weird issue with
freebsd 8 we're like it competes for
kernel resources with Erlang and Erlang
is trying to like run on this 48 cores
and we don't know how they're like
there's some contention in a kernel if
only we could figure it out we just need
some l and like and we knew that he
loves doing this kind of stuff right so
like so with him we played the different
angle it took us a few months to
convince him but eventually he joined
and he helped us fix a lot of
bottlenecks in our system so so there
were all different stories but I think
they bulk up the initial kind of core of
people who joined there were from our
professional and personal networks
yes I'm fortunate oh man all right if
you got time I will go through one more
question thank you oh I think what
happens to a role model so get up being
focused I want to understand your
decision-making process how when you get
feedback from users how you define is
that the deploys how you define in such
a feature we need to improve and how you
define how I find out as the efficiency
of communicating is the core feature you
want and focus on for so many years how
do we know what features to build on
stitchers not to build and you're
absolutely right because in the early
days people would write in and say we
want user names over one pin because
people were so conditioned by all these
messaging apps and that came before us
that you need to have a user name or pin
so like if you were using bbm or
people using AIESEC you you have like
some random pit that you would have to
exchange with people or if you were
using Skype or yahoo messenger you have
to have a username and people didn't
understand that we were building was
like this whole new idea of like you
don't need any of that stuff you just
sign up with your number and it's
connected to your phone that has the
same phone number and you go and so in
early days a lot of feedback we did from
users was useful they're like we want
groups were one multimedia we want to
have additional privacy controls we want
to turn off our last scene great we've
built a lot of what people ask but also
didn't build what people ask because we
didn't think it was the right fit for a
product like having the fundamental
belief and the gut feeling that what
you're doing is right
and having that that like vision of it's
just going to work I'm going to build it
using phone numbers I'm not going to
have user names and I'm going to have
stance because it makes product more
complicated it makes product harder to
use people forget their user names and
pins and all that stuff like having that
that belief in yourself and in the tag
and knowing that that what you're
building is going to work is obviously
also important so that's kind of how we
would make decisions okay you know
animals music ever the one game huh yeah
yeah what has it been about - the usual
or futures it could issue of the
messenger what I feel about Siri is your
vision security issues are for us well
we as you know we rolled out into an
encryption and we weren't the first ones
to do it
obviously there were apps before us that
that focused on security but we were the
first ones to do it on such a global
scale for everybody seamlessly right I
mean there is no other app today that
has more than a billion people that has
entered encryption enabled by default
into everything you do individual chats
group chats and everything else so we
didn't start out again this kind of goes
back to what we started with it was just
a pure one-on-one messaging right there
was no group chats the razón
Multimedia's there was no end to end
encryption there was no video call ins
there was no voice : there was none of
that but over years we made a commitment
to our users so who were going to add
all these features and we're going to
make them work and make them work really
well and so obviously we feel strong is
that encryption is important
and we feel strongly about into an
encryption which is why we added it and
watch is why which is why we have it in
our application today thank you
[Applause]